دخان حرائق كندا يخنق جيرانها الولايات
المتحده اول المتضررين وقد لا تكون اخرهم
السلطات الكنديه اعلنت محاولتها اخماد نحو
423 حريقا
246 منها خارجه عن السيطره تسببت الحرائق
بالقضاء على حوالي ثلاثه ملايين 800 الف
هكتار فيما تحولت مقاطعه للحرائق حيث ينشط
فيها 160 حريقا الى جانب عشرات الحرائق
الاخرى في البرتا وكولومبيا البريطانيه
وانتاريو دخان حرائق الغابات القادمه من
كندا سيؤثر على اكثر من 55 مليون شخص في
مناطق الشمال الشرقي ووسط الولايات
المتحده ابرزها نيويورك وبوسطن وواشنطن
نيويورك المعروفه عاده بسماعها الصافيه
سجلت اسوا مؤشر لجوده الهواء عالميا وفق
موقع اي كيو ار السويسري المختص في مراقبه
حاله الهواء
بانتقال الحرائق الى غابات الولايات
المتحده المتاخمه على بعد اكثر من
5800 كيلو متر من كندا حيث تقع النرويج
يتوقع ان تدفع الرياح بدخان الحرائق الى
هناك وفق مسؤولين نرويجيين حيث سجلت
جزيئات متطايره من الدخان جنوبيا النرويج
بينما تحرك الدخان فوق جرينلاند وايسلندا
منذ الاول من يونيو الحكومه الكنديه تتوقع
استمرار نشاط الحرائق بصوره اعلى من
المعتاد وصدبابيه توقيت ومكان توقف السحب
الدخانيه وعوده الهواء لطبيعته لارتباطها
باتجاه الرياح وسرعتها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات